those nominated for the best performance
by an actor are Marlon Brando Viva
Zapata 20th Century Fox Gary Cooper high
noon Kramer United Artists Kirk Douglas
the bad in the beautiful MGM Jose Ferrer
Moulin Rouge Romulus United Artists and
Alec Guinness the Lavender Hill mob
ranked Ealing universal international in
the absence of the winter John Wayne
will accept the award for Gary Cooper
gentlemen I'm glad to see that they're
giving this to a man who was not only
most deserving but has conducted himself
throughout his years in our business in
a manner that we can all be proud of it
coupe and I have been friends hunting
and fishing for more years and I like to
remember he's one of the nicest fellows
I know I don't know anybody any nicer
and our kinship goes further than that
friendship because we both fell off the
horses into pictures together now that I
am through being such a good sport
spouted all this good sportsmanship I'm
going to go back and find my business
manager an agent producer and serene
named writer and find out why I didn't
get high known instead of Cooper I can't
fire any of these very expensive fellows
but I at least run my 1930 Chevrolet
into one of their big black new catalog